you can't have it no candy corn okay
that's what's it called candy corn you
don't like candy corn you like that you
like candy corn you eat candy what the
[__] maybe it's a white guy thing look
at doors you like candy corn candy corn
is delicious oh yeah what's the flavor
honey sugar yeah yeah it's delicious I
love sugar though no sugar I got just
dip your [__] finger in a [__]
bowl of sugar then no there's fun to
like eat the little white tip and then
eat the orange like can you change the
flavors of the colors at least they they
lazy white candy making classic I'm
tired of lazy white candy making you go
to a [__] Japanese oh my God right
okay they have [__] juice in it yeah
that you can eat the paper sometimes
yeah right why yeah why are you so lazy
at making candy uh